earlier this week Black Panther made
Oscar history as the first superhero
movie nominated for Best Picture now add
this big honor the Black Panther himself
out in front of Vanity Fair's
star-studded Hollywood Issue Chadwick
Boseman Oscar nominee Rami Malek and
crazy rich Asians Henry Golding are
among the celebs who nabbed the coveted
cover we have people from all over the
world on it it reflects the society that
we're living in right now and it
certainly reflects what Hollywood looks
like the magazine is celebrating the
25th anniversary of the special issue
where over the years just about every
big star you can imagine is taking part
[Music]
last year was the infamous Photoshop
fail where Oprah was accidentally given
three hands and it appeared Rhys at
three legs how many hands the very first
Hollywood Issue in 1995 made news
because it featured actresses in the
cult Kidman Sandra Bullock and Sarah
Jessica Parker who were all
provocatively dressed and ended a
controversy because we were wearing
lingerie or something right very time
for now but back then not so time one of
the most memorable covers was 2013 Ben
Affleck in a bear costume Bradley Cooper
in a gorilla suit and both in bed with
Emma Stone leaned back point let it rip
we've also seen a star show off hidden
talents from Jay laws mouth marionette
to Cate Blanchett's blip haha there we
go Anne Hathaway first made the
Hollywood Issue in 2008 it was a really
exciting time and I was also happy
Emily's
we just really bonded on the numbers
Prada so to be there with one of my
favorite people that I've met at my job
you know it was really special and look
at babyface Leo and Matthew from 1996 I
remember that
I look like I'm caught between a smile
and swallowing or something know what I
call cheese not your best shot Makana
yep that's me
[Music]
[Applause]